I am a flower.
Yes, I'm beautiful.
I've heard it before.
And it never grows old.
I'm worshipped for my looks, my scent, my looks.
But here's the thing.
Life starts with me.
You see, I feed people.
Every fruit comes from me.
Every potato, me.
Every kernel of corn, me.
Every grain of rice, me.
Me, me, me, I know, but it's true.
And sometimes I feed their souls.
I am their words when they have none.
I say "I love you" without a sound.
"I'm sorry" without a voice.
I inspire the greatest of them.
Painters, poets, pattern makers, I've been a muse to them all.
But in my experience, people underestimate the power of a pretty little flower.
Because their life does start with me.
And it could end without me.